Lake Powell and Lake Mead are at their
lowest levels ever part of the drought
that is decimating what's left of the
Colorado River water supply and today
officials from the federal government
revealed their strategy on how to deal
with the crisis going forward a news now
investigator Kyle Payne at the
government's press conference at the
Hoover Dam today
right before the press conference the
Bureau of Reclamation dropped its
500-page report outlining their plans to
handle the short supply of water on the
Colorado River what seems unbelievable
though Nevada's representative at the
meeting was learning about these
proposals at the same time we were do
you think Nevada with this agreement
might be taking it on the chin well I
haven't had a chance to read anything
that's in this document yet but
obviously it's my job to fight and make
sure we don't take it on the channel
John Ensminger general manager of the
Southern Nevada Water Authority it's a
beautiful day in Nevada and the other
Representatives joining Bureau of
Reclamation commissioner Camille Tuten
last June I briefed Congress on the
science of the Colorado River Basin the
risks we saw to the system and the
action we needed to stabilize the system
hadn't read the 476-page federal
government report outlining how the
states affected by the Colorado River
plan to divvy up that precious water but
he knew enough to share his opinion that
this is perhaps not the solution
Southern nevadans were hoping for
there's not a lot of nuance even in 476
Pages not a lot of nuance the unnuanced
proposal by The Bureau lists three
emergency options and they want the
states and residents to read through
them and help decide how to move forward
starting in January of next year the
first course of action is no action
where they would leave things just the
way they are the second option is what
they call Action Plan and one which
would Divide Colorado River Water By
Priority using the existing century-old
water rights and the final option is
called action plan 2 which would
essentially divide the water using a
percentage system based on actual water
usage if I had a crystal ball my
prediction would be that there will be
fourth fifth sixth Alternatives proposed
and sminger did not speak at today's
press conference his counterpart a
representative from Arizona took the mic
instead we're on a bit of a
merry-go-round we got to get off the
Merry-Go-Round we need to have an
outcome in which the cuts are big enough
that we don't have to do these Emergency
Operations every few months the public
has 45 days to look at the 500 page
course of action and comment as for the
three possible strategies officials told
us they expect to hear a lot of good
ideas and it's most likely we'll see
them try to use a combination of the
different approaches public comment
starts on Friday
thank you Kyle today's announcement is
part of President Biden's investing in
America agenda that infrastructure law
provides 8.3 billion dollars over the
next five years to enhance drought
resistance to secure dams among other
things